Kylie Jenner and Forbes might be feuding
over her billionaire status but the
magazine still gave her the number-one
spot on their 2020 celeb 100 list which
ranks the world's highest-paid celebs
based on annual pay thank you the list
was released on Thursday and according
to Forbes the 22 year old earned five
hundred and ninety million dollars over
the past year which can mostly be
attributed to Cody buying a 51% stake of
Kylie cosmetics last January she sold it
for a whopping 600 million dollars which
led to her earning five hundred and
forty million dollars pre-tax she works
really hard the mag also named Kylie's
brother-in-law Kanye West as the second
highest-paid celeb this year according
to Forbes he earned one hundred and
seventy million dollars over the past
year mostly because of his popular
fashion line Yeezy the magazine
estimates his net worth at 1.3 billion
dollars
rounding out the top ten highest paid
celebs Roger Federer Cristiano Ronaldo
Lionel Messi Tyler Perry
Neymar Howard Stern LeBron James and
Dwyane Johnson Forbes was the first
publication to label Kylie a billionaire
back in 2019 and doubled down on the
claim she was a self-made billionaire in
2020 starting a company on my own and it
being so big from the beginning there's
not a lot of room for mistakes but in an
article published last month the mag
accused Kylie of lying about her
earnings for years and claimed that she
backed up the numbers with falsified tax
returns
Kylie hit up Twitter to straight-up deny
it
Kylie wrote in part quote I've never
asked for any title or tried to lie my
way there ever period that was my true
fans to know it's worth pointing out
that forbes is now estimating Kylie's
net worth to be nine hundred million
dollars it's not like that was
to her she figured that all out on
Monday a source told ET that now Kylie
just wants people to stop focusing on
how much money she has adding this whole
thing seems to be a clickbait attempt
for Forbes meanwhile Kylie's attorney
Michael Kampf released a statement about
the whole thing saying that the article
is filled with outright lies and
demanding that the mag issue a
retraction quote it is sad that of all
things forbes has devoted three
reporters to investigate the effect of
the coronavirus crisis on Kylie's net
worth we would not expect that from a
supermarket tabloid much less from
Forbes
[Music]